[موسيقى]
عندما نتحدث عن انتقال الطاقة ،
أعتقد أولاً أن هذا هو المكان الذي يوجد فيه
الكثير من أمن الطاقة الآن علينا
أن نتحول من الطريقة القديمة للوقود الأحفوري
إلى الطريقة الجديدة
وعلينا إزالة الكربون عن الرحلة بأكملها ،
لذا إذا  نحن قادرون على تطوير
تقنية يمكننا من خلالها توليد
الطاقة الصافية الصفرية ،
أعتقد أن هذا هو الحل الذي
سنعمل عليه سواء كان ذلك للتجديد أو
من خلال التقنيات الجديدة التي
نعمل عليها والتي تستفيد من
جزء من الوقود الأحفوري في مكان ما  أود أن
أقول إنك تعلم أن هذا هو المكان
الذي يمكنك فيه الوصول إلى الشمس كثيرًا
ومن دواعي امتيازك أن تحصل على كليهما ،
أود أن أقول
إن الوقود الأحفوري الذي
كان يقود العالم حتى الآن ويمضي
قدمًا ما هو  مطلوب وهو
متجدد وأعتقد أن هذا هو المكان الذي يوجد فيه
هذا الجزء من العالم
بفرصته القوية لإنشاء أه جيجاوات
من الطاقة المتجددة وخاصة الطاقة الشمسية
إلى جانب التخزين أه أعتقد أن
لدينا حل هنا
سيضعك في المقدمة  أود أن أقول بالمقارنة مع
بقية الاقتصاد
الأجنبي
[الموسيقى]
ما نريده هو
اعتماد أسرع لمصادر الطاقة المتجددة نريد
اعتمادًا أسرع للانتقال إلى الكهربة ،
وهذا هو الأسرع الذي يمكننا اعتماده ، وكلما
تمكنا من تمكين الحكومات بشكل أسرع
التمكين من خلال السياسة من خلال إنشاء
البنية التحتية ، خذ على سبيل المثال
المركبات الكهربائية التي هي
الشكل الأكثر كفاءة لأنك تعلم أه
أنك تشغل العجلات مباشرة
من خلال المحرك الكهربائي وكلما زادت
السيارات الكهربائية قادمة على الطريق
أقل بكثير أه تعرف الطاقة  التي
تريدها من الوقود الأحفوري
ويمكنك استبدالها بالطاقة النظيفة وهو
ما هو متاح هنا